el aeropuerto de palma se llena de miles
de turistas alemanes
[Música]
hace unos días en promedio 80 vuelos
estaban programados diariamente el de
alemania y la isla principal de las
baleares cuatro veces más que de
costumbre
queríamos descubrir las islas aprovechar
el sol y sobre todo tras un año de
pandemia queríamos ver otra cosa
queremos escuchar hablar de otra cosa
[Música]
cuando somos basándonos
en la línea costera disfrutan de los
rayos del sol sin tapabocas pero también
de los bares y restaurantes abiertos
hasta las 17 horas las restricciones son
más flexibles que en alemania pero no
preocupan a los turistas
creo que hay 4 veces menos contagios que
en alemania es más seguro aquí nos
decimos la pcr antes de venir entonces
creo que aquí todo el mundo dio negativo
sin embargo angela merkel les
desaconsejó a los alemanes que viajarán
a españa aquí todos desafiaron dichas
recomendaciones
tal vez no nos crea capaces de respetar
las distancias de seguridad pero yo sé
reflexionar sé lo que es bueno para mí y
soy responsable desde la flexibilización
de las restricciones la tasa de
incidencia se duplicó en la isla la
llegada de los alemanes genera inquietud
en pleno recrudecimiento de la familia
estamos en un momento crítico en el que
no sabemos si los alemanes aumentarán el
contagio y será más difícil para
nosotros muy bien para nuestra economía
porque el turismo es el primer motor de
la isla 80% de su economía depende de
esta empresa organiza visitas en las
calles de la ciudad
álex les enseña a los alemanes a hacerse
güey
tras un año de paro retomar la actividad
es un asunto de supervivencia yo he
tenido que buscar otra alternativa de
trabajo diferente al turismo he tenido
que ir haciendo mis costillas durante
todo este tiempo y ahora pues parece que
nos están dando un respiro y que vamos a
poder trabajar no el sector está
pidiendo que se abran las fronteras y se
facilite el ingreso de turistas diría
que un 60 65 por ciento es internacional
un 35 40 por ciento es nacional así que
sí tanto es importante que habrá en el
turismo internacional como el nacional
así que las fronteras los extranjeros
pueden venir a españa pero los
habitantes no pueden abandonar su región
las fronteras de las comunidades
autónomas están cerradas está madrileña
es la primera víctima de ello
imposible verse con su novio que vive en
valencia
esta fue la última foto que nos hicimos
juntos pues desde estas navidades
llevamos sin vernos por suerte pudo
un justificante y desplazarse a
madrid
un par de días por motivo de trabajo
él se fue y ya nunca más lo nos hemos
vuelto a ver la verdad que se está
haciendo muy largo
puede terminar incluso nuestra relación
porque la distancia pues es difícil la
verdad una situación que está española
vive como una injusticia para esta
organización que defiende el sector
turístico del país es una aberración
no tiene ningún sentido que un ciudadano
alemán pueda venir desde berlín
francés desde parís a madrid y un
ciudadano amadrinó pueda ir a toledo que
está a 60 km de distancia y que a lo
mejor de unos inciden unos niveles de
incidencia mucho más bajos que los
territorios de otros países los
extranjeros pueden venir a españa
presentando una pcr negativa este
representante propone que los españoles
puedan cambiar la región en las mismas
condiciones en madrid las autoridades
regionales piden esta flexibilización
pero por ahora la capital sólo puede
acoger a los extranjeros entre ellos a
decenas de miles de franceses en fuga
le prestan atención al tapabocas hay que
respetar eso respetando lo se puede
salir ver gente hablar ir a los
restaurantes tener vida social
pero estas medidas no son respetadas por
todo el mundo esta asociación de vecinos
denuncia ciertos comportamientos es una
situación insostenible e insoportable
máxime cuando ellos están tomando todo
tipo de precauciones todo tipo de
medidas de prevención y sin embargo como
estamos viendo pues la mayoría de la
gente no lo está cumpliendo entonces eso
es algo que irrita bastante a la gente
resultó que de quedar a las 11 de la
noche las fiestas continúan en los
apartamentos y ahora lo que tenemos es
turismo de borrachera están entrando a
comprar alcohol y de ahí pues
probablemente salen con las bolsas y van
a pisos turísticos a seguir la fiesta
claro vas a estar en un apartamento
turístico con mascarilla pues no
españa está bloqueada entre el riesgo
sanitario y la salvación de su economía
el turismo representa 25 millones de
empleos y el 13 por ciento de la
actividad española